hi there steve kaufman here um
my wife is playing the piano in the
background it's a rainy
sunday here in vancouver a little bit of
musical accompaniment
today i'm going to talk about learning
and my belief that learning
has to come before studying
in other words it's very difficult to
study something
that you haven't already learned
naturally in some way and this is
particularly true
of languages
and unfortunately most of our
educational situations involve
an attempt to teach
or an attempt to study something
which we haven't already become familiar
with
i remember once
driving home in tokyo in the 70s
listening to nhk radio they had a
program or they had an educational
channel
and i heard this sound coming from my
radio in my car and it went something
like this
and this went on and on
and i thought it was some kind of
buddhist chant
and then i found out that this was their
radio english lesson
i don't know what they were trying to
achieve
uh i remember buying a korean cd and i
still remember that they began with all
the sounds of korean
uh which you had to listen to and repeat
you didn't know what they meant
and i still remember these sounds all
new paul pew i can't i don't know what
it means i never came across those
sounds or words again but that's
what they had there for you
um
you know and uh
when you like i can remember two
starting into my russian a lot of the
books will give you a whole list of
cognates words that are
similar to other languages
two pages three pages worth what can i
possibly do with those words i can't
possibly learn them
however
if i come across them
and discover them i'll be very happy to
find a freebie
word in russian that i already know from
some other language but i can't possibly
take them all at once until i have had
that exposure to russian the same with
grammar rules you know in russian for
example one rule that came at me fairly
early was that for numbers if you are if
it's one year then it's in the year is
in the nominativ if it's two three or
four it's in the genitive singular but
if it's five or more it's in the
genitive plural
and
that's one as in 21 31 41 it doesn't
matter
um
yeah okay you know kind of understand
what you're saying there but if that and
if that was the only rule i had to learn
in russian
you know i might
be able to pick up on that when you
consider that there are so many rules
rules about
cases and you know the same ending can
be
the genitive the accusative the plural
nominative depending on gender and
whatever
uh
you know sometimes the case it's the ac
it's in the it's the uh it'll be this
ending if it's
animate like animal or person or some
other ending if it's not animal
the verb to go depending on whether
you're going on foot on by train or by
car is different depending on whether
you're going and coming back or you're
just going
you know all of these things that are
very difficult to understand
particularly when you have no reference
point
none
uh
now that i've been studying russian for
three years
these things are starting to seem
natural to me i can now go back to a
grammar book
and read this thing and it starts to
make sense
the same is true
with um
with sounds you know you have all these
rules
that
you know and they'll even try and teach
you this
you know when such a letter comes next
to some other letter the one will
influence the other and it's kind of
pronounced differently
so uh there you know i can't remember
all these rules
but and then they introduced the
phonetic alphabet stuff but if you've
never heard the word before what's the
phonetic alphabet going to do for you
um so
my big thing is you can focus on
studying something on refining things
once you've got the language in you
there was a comment
on my you know let the words overflow
video where i said the main thing is
just to let the words come at you learn
some forget some get some get some
familiarity with the language and work
on gaining these words
uh and don't worry about what you forget
and so someone commented on my youtube
video here well yes but i think you have
to work on grammar and words grammar and
vocabulary at the same time
nice theory
i can't do it
if you give me two or three things about
the language like
verb comes at the end
a couple of things like that i might be
able to remember them but very quickly
it's
overload it's tilt i can't make head or
tail of it
until i have had a lot of exposure to
the language
i had a similar comment from someone
on where i had said you know in terms of
accent reduction you know don't
deliberately focus on that especially
not at the beginning
just
listen and if you want to project
yourself
into that culture that language and
imitate that person
you'll be able to do it slowly you'll
get better and better at it
and this person sort of said well you
know you really should work on your
accents so i said well why would you say
that and they came back and said well
because when you spoke portuguese you
didn't sound very good you had strong
spanish
uh influence on your portuguese well
first of all i have never claimed
to be native-like in any of the
languages that i speak it's not my goal
i have never tried to do that
i try to imitate the native speaker but
i don't pretend
that my goal
is to achieve
such a degree of
accentless whatever liners that people
would mistake me for a native speaker
they will not however while i speak it i
will betray somewhere that i'm not a
native speaker
and languages that i'm not working on
that hard like portuguese
of course i'm gonna have a spanish
accent people tell me i have a french
accent in my german
uh
so what
uh i mean if i were an actor
and i had a role where i had to pretend
that i spoke
portuguese like a brazilian or like a
portuguese then that's very specific
then i would work at it i might get a
special coach to coach me on my accent
but if my main goal is to enjoy the
language
communicate
enjoy myself i'm not going to worry
about those things
so i guess what i'm saying here is
that a lot of sort of deliberate
studying deliberate instruction
is almost counterproductive
that there is this
sufist saying that you can't
learn what you don't already know i
would put it a different way i would say
that you can't deliberately study
something that you haven't already
learned or experienced
um
i think the brain works that way things
come through the brain kind of picks up
on it a little bit it goes in there
somewhere in the head then you get at it
again and you get it like i'll often if
i start a new language before we had
link i would go out and buy
teach yourself
korean colloquial korean somebody else's
pimsleur korean assimil korean not
pimple because he's got too much english
on there but asimil
and so then i would listen to the same
stuff from three or four different
sources so again i'm just passing it
through the hippocampus if you want
passing it through my brain it settles
in there somewhere then very similar
content comes at me from another
direction and slowly slowly i'm sort of
layering
stuff in there that's going to stick and
once i have enough of that then i might
want to go in and study because there
will be things that i don't notice there
will be things that can be pointed out
in a grammar book can be pointed out by
sort of saying well you know really you
may have not have noticed but
uh
in whatever language they tend to drop
this vowel before this constant and so
you can see stuff there that oh yeah
right i kind of wondered about that or
or even i never noticed and so at that
point these little things can come along
and help you but they are just
supplementary to the main task of
learning which i believe is done before
you actually start studying so my advice
is before you study something
try to learn it
bye for now